♪ ♪ ♪
- La région métropolitaine de
Montréalau cours des 20 dernièrs
années. Résultat : moins de
personnes occupent désormais
un plus grand espace
en
- À la place d'avoir
trois salles de baint-t-t-ce
qu'on peut en mettre deux?
Un qui répond aux objectifst t .
- Kim Pariseau et son équipe
d'architectes tentent de
s'attaquer à l'étalement urbain
de maisons unifamiliales.
KIM PAAUAUAU, architecte et
fondat., Appareil Architecture
- On doit prendre notre petite
un multigénérationnel. On veut
r r r r autant de pieds carrés.
On veut vivre dans du grand
au Québec. On veut avoir accèsts
trop de trouble non plus.OnOnOn.
On veut que ça dure longtemps.
On veut de la qualité.vovovovovs
nécessairement dire la
construction de tours à condos
les unes sur les autres, selon
CHRISTIAN SAVARD, directeur
l,l,l,l, Vivre en ville
- Si on regarde ici un peu
à gauche, ça commence à être
mais on a également faitdededed.
On a du trois-quatre étages
jusqu'ici. On s'autour d'un pare
patrimonial, hein, ici,
c'est la gare Dalhousie.
mis quelques années à germer
avant d'être acceptée dans
certains quartiers de Montréal.
dans Rosemont, qu'on disait que
c'était tout pareil, puis que
c'était uniforme et que c'étaitt
y ajouter des parcs, lorsque
les arbres deviennent matures,
lorsque le temps a faite e e e z
souvent que ça s'améliore.
- Je comprends très bien
les gens qui veulent pas vivre-.
- Pour le chroniqueur
Olivier Niquet, il faut rendre
les villes plus attractives.
en urbanisme et chroniqueur
- L'idée, c'est de rendr
ces tours-là à 12 étages...
ou à moins, plus agréables pour
"Ah bien, peut-être que
si j'habite dans u
plus dense où j'ai une belle
qualité de vie, mes enfants vont
y a des commerces de proximité,
je peux aller cocococococourses
à pieds, il y a des parcs et
tout ça, bien, ils auront pasane
éloignée juste pour avoir
leur grande cours, t'sais.ébébéé
en juin dernier sa première
"Politique nationale
de l'architecture etrererererer,
qui a mis la densification c c ,
si les attentes sont grandes,
les résultats, eux, se f
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.